dans une rare sortie à l'extérieur de la
capitale volodymyr zelensky s'est rendu
dans le sud du pays le président a
profité de son passage à la base de la
garde nationale à odessa pour saluer ses
troupes puis il s'est rendu dans la
ville de miku lève pour constater
l'ampleur des dégâts l'endroit est la
cible des forces russes depuis le début
de leur invasion une frappe qui a fait
deux morts et 20 blessés vendredi cette
ville portuaire et industrielle est
toujours sous contrôle ukrainien mais
l'étau se resserre pour les combattants
sur le terrain
nos gardes et les soldats russes sont
plus d'armée plus d'obus ils bombardent
surtout les villages on leur a tiré
dessus et ils se vengent sur les
quartiers résidentiels dit ce soldat est
allé à l'arrière d'un véhicule rempli de
munitions moyenne mais nous devons
travailler rapidement et sortir de la
position aussi rapidement nous en
dépendent
et parmi les soldats qui sont tristement
morts au combat on compte romane
ratushny suis alors qu'il avait 24 ans
dans la région de kharkiv
figure importante du mouvement de
protestation pro-européenne maiden en
2013 qui avait provoqué le départ du
président pro russe viktor ianoukovitch
en 2014 ses funérailles ont attiré des
milliers de personnes à kiev dont le
maire de la capitale vitali klitschko
plusieurs considèrent ce jeune militant
comme un héros national
je tiens à te remercier mon fils pour
tout ce que tu as fait en si peu de
temps vois tu combien de gens sont ici
aujourd'hui tu as changé la vie de tant
de personnes a dit son père bouleversée
même si je ne le connaissais pas
personnellement je le perçois comme une
perte personnelle
romane est une personne qui a influencé
ma vision du monde et qui je suis
maintenant dit cette jeune femme de 20
ans ici marie michel lauzon radio canada
montréal